matthew mcconaughey and camila alvez's
children look so grown up check out the
couple with their three kids 13 year old
levi 11 year old veda and nine-year-old
livingston attending the sing 2 premiere
in l.a they like coming to set
they like seeing what their popeye does
mama camila shares some snaps on her
instagram giving sweet shout outs to her
hubby and kids we always have our family
as
you know i i call it the traveling
circus that's what i call it
the first tribute a pic of her two sons
with their dad writing quote the three
most important male presents in my life
what a blessing to see the boy so big
the second post a touching message for
their daughter the caption reading in
part quote look at veda guys this young
lady has changed my life my partner in
crime one of a kind well it's gonna be a
big thing for like the kids i would
imagine the kids think that's kind of
cool oh i'm much
i've got more street cred at the dinner
table now that i'm in in the sings
e.t caught up with matthew at the
premiere where the father of three
talked all about how his kiddos are
finally excited to see a movie their dad
is in i haven't made many they can see
so finally making something they can see
they dig them they still they they know
i made it
but yet when we got to the theater to
watch it and they see buster moon come
on voice comes out think it sounds like
it's their dad they look over at me they
look back at the screen look over me
look back at the screen look over me
black at the screen then they get a big
smile on their face i won't let you down
sir better not or i'll throw you off the
roof mcconaughey returns as the lovable
koala in the seeing sequel which is full
of recognizable tunes
i knew you were a winner
and speaking of music the oscar winner
tells e.t there is plenty of it at the
mcconaughey house we've been doing a lot
of chuck berry lately um which is some
original rock and roll and a really
unique guitar um
everyone gets their chance to to play dj
sometimes i've got one child that
loves orchestral
really already at a young age really
does not like to hear vocals on anything
like to says his imagination works
better with forming a story in his mind
when there are no vocals um we've
introduced them to african music ali
farcatore oh love blues to rock and roll
to country to um some jazz
not much um and then obviously they
introduce us to some
more poppets bpm hits and that are
really catchy um sophia the first is a
tune that that they're singing right now
that i've that i may know the lyrics to
by hearing it from them so much